now when we talk about science of
compassion it's also tied up with
science of empathy you know empathy
compassion altruism kindness they are
all very interrelated and much of the
current scientific studies really fall
into two main categories one is a study
of altruistic behavior particularly in
animal and very young children and the
thinking is that if we can see
altruistic behavior in animal and very
very young children that it must have
very deep biological roots so that's the
kind of logic behind why they are
focusing more on animal studies and
children the other important area that
overlaps the science of compassion is
the study of empathy and again here a
lot of the work has been done on
non-human primate studies there is an
American professor at Emory by the name
of France de Waal and he was one of the
pioneers many you know people might have
seen the video of you know apes in you
know there were two juvenile Apes
apes fighting and one of them loses
another ape who's not a blood relation
comes over and hugs him and gives and
consoles him so it clearly is an
indication that empathy can be found in
non-human primates as well and then
there are some interesting studies
coming from the studies of meditators
who meditate many hours on compassion
and then looking at their brain you can
actually see the brains expression in
action so this is called functioning you
know MRI which is which has the ability
to look at the brain in act in action as
it were at least the claim is that the
meditators are unlike novices like us
have some ability to consciously direct
their attention and thoughts so in the
scanner the brain imaging scanner you
can ask the military can you do this can
you do that can you just stay on the
level of empathy and feel the pain now
can you move on to compassion wishing
the other person to be free of suffering
and wanting to do something about it and
try to tease out what brain signature
and brain regions
activated when you're just an empathy
feeling and when you are moving on to
compassion when you are wishing to see
the relief in this way the whole mapping
of the brain regions that are involved
in an experience something like
compassion is beginning to be done